Speaker 1: I missed this and did not have
time to talk about it until today.
This guy from Newsmax, Rob Murphy, who is
on the bandwagon attacking me on Twitter over
the last few days for the controversy about
the Nashville shooting he interviewed failed
former President Donald Trump, and Trump said
something bizarre.
Donald Trump said that he appointed Ron DeSantis
governor.
Now, that didn't happen.
It simply didn't happen.
There's no way in which that could even be
remotely interpreted as accurate.
Listen to this strangeness about Ron DeSantis.
Speaker 2: He told Eric BOLLING last night
that he thinks the New York Alvin Bragg probe
is a political stunt by George Soros.
He also said he would not consider being your
vice president in 2024.
I want to ask, was was that ever an option
for you?
Speaker 6: No, I never thought of it.
I think that we have a lot of great people
in the Republican Party.
I never thought of it, but you know, some
people.
Every once in a while mentioned it, but that's
about it.
No, I think that would be a very unlikely
alliance.
But, you know, look, I appointed him.
He was failing badly in the past.
He was out of politics.
He was going to be out of politics.
And I endorsed him.
And he went from a very small number to a
very high number of you.
Speaker 1: You appointed him.
What on earth does that mean?
Is this Trump mean that his endorsement was
such a life saver to desanctis that it was
like an appointment?
Trump saying I endorse you is almost as good
as Trump saying I appoint you the governor
of Florida.
Very, very strange.
Trump then talking about January 6th, and
he says he made beautiful statements despite
the fact that he incited a riot.
Speaker 6: President of the United States.
I made beautiful statements.
If you look at my statements, I wish you could
read them off to your viewers, which, by the
way, I see you're doing very well.
So I'm proud of you, Rep. Yeah, but I wish
you could read them off to the viewers.
But I called for peace.
I called for all of these different things.
On numerous occasions, Yes.
Speaker 1: He also used the words fight or
fighting more than 20 times and quite literally
incited a riotous mob.
Trump asked about DeSantis more, and he went
after DeSantis for his COVID numbers, which
is super interesting.
I'll explain why in a moment.
Speaker 2: You both.
But that's that's politics.
As we move into primary season here, I want
to ask, what do you have to get the word.
Speaker 6: Out, though?
And, you know, I don't like saying this about
another Republican, but you have to you know,
everyone thought he did great on COVID.
But if you look at the list, he did poorly
on COVID.
He was in the numbers, the same numbers as
New York.
A little bit worse in New York is bad on education,
better on COVID.
There are many different things that people
don't know about.
Speaker 1: So now you know what?
Trump is right.
It's just funny because Florida to Republicans
is either the shining beacon of freedom and
liberty in a sea of wokeness when it's convenient,
or it's sort of like not that great.
If you want to criticize.
Ron DeSantis and I have made this case before,
Florida's per capita COVID death rate is very
so-so.
It's not the worst and it's not the best.
It's just like kind of mediocre.
That's true.
Trump's right education in Florida.
It's not very good.
It's not as bad as in Arkansas, Mississippi,
but it's not very good either it's not Connecticut
or New York or Massachusetts or Maine.
So Trump actually is right here.
It's just funny that they're only they're
only willing to say this stuff.
We all know.
When it's convenient for them, which shouldn't
come as a shock.
Trump was asked about his choice to hold that
rally over the weekend in Waco, Texas, on
the 30th anniversary of the Waco siege.
He completely ignores the question.
Speaker 2: About this rally tomorrow in Waco,
Texas.
You're holding a massive rally.
It's going to be televised here on Newsmax,
of course.
Next month marks 30 years, though, since that
deadly government siege of the Branch Davidian
compound there.
We've got the mainstream media right now accusing
you of, quote, stoking the fires of Waco.
With this visit and with that location.
I just wanted to get your thoughts on that
and what people can expect from the rally
tomorrow.
Speaker 6: Yeah, well, I hear there's tens
of thousands of people.
I mean, we're going to have, you know, many,
many tens of thousands.
The line is already miles long, trying to
get in.
And I don't believe until tomorrow, late afternoon.
And we're going to have a great time in Waco.
We're going to have a great time in Texas.
I won Texas by a lot, two times, as you know.
And we have tremendous support in Texas.
We have a lot of the congressmen are coming.
A lot of the great people in politics are
coming.
And most importantly, the people of Texas
are going.
We're going to have it's going to be a very
big rally.
We're just now starting our rallies because
people love the rallies and we're just now
starting to rally.
So this will be about the first one that we've
done.
We've done interior things.
But this is the first major rally, and I think
they're bigger than ever before.
I think I really see it.
Okay.
Speaker 1: So again, Trump not answering the
actual question about the fact that he's in
Waco and all of the imagery and all of the
insanity of doing that.
And then lastly here, Trump going after his
former lawyer and friend of The David Pakman
Show Michael Cohen.
Speaker 6: It's just the opposite.
And then on top of that, you had which may
have been even a bigger factor, you have a
letter that talks about this whole thing in
exactly the opposite way, which really showed
that Cohen was lying.
He was lying badly, but he's known for that.
You know, he's sort of a con man.
And then he was a lawyer.
He represented other people.
And you're supposed to have a certain allegiance
to a client.
You know, nowadays that doesn't mean so much
with all of these prosecutors out there that
just.
Speaker 1: So Trump bemoaning that even his
own lawyers aren't loyal to him.
Really deranged interview celebrated by Newsmax.
There will be much more of this to come, and
I predict it is going to get much, much worse
from the things that Trump has been posting
to troth.
Essentially, I think this sort of insanity
is only going to get worse.